the catastrophic derailment happened on
a raised embankment next to an
irrigation canal carriages jackknifed
the passenger compartments ending up
laid on their sides down the slope
the Hazara Express is a daily service
linking the southern city of Karachi
with the northern province of khyberpak
tonkwa the crash happened near nawabza
city in the southern Sindh Province and
passengers from the still upright
carriages were the first to help quickly
joined by dozens of local rescues
there were chaotic scenes at the trauma
center in nawabza as a stream of
ambulances and private carts ferried the
injured for treatment the victims
including men women and children many
were covered in blood many looked dazed
and in shock
outside the medical center the bodies of
those less fortunate were laid out on
the concrete floor
the cause of the derailment isn't known
footage of the Doral carriages showed
the wheels and bogeys had separated from
the passenger compartment initial
theories are focused on either
mechanical failure or even possible
sabotage
the rescue process has begun all the
relevant departments have been directed
to take all necessary actions by prime
minister Sharif he has ordered a
thorough investigation into this and has
promised he will reveal the reasons for
this accident
more than 80 million passengers use
Pakistan's Railway system and accidents
and derailments occur all too frequently
but the immediate priority is trying to
find survivors and recover the Dead
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera